bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7-8 sport
l'émission consacrée comme vous le savez
à l'actualité sportive dans le
département tout de suite le sommaire de
votre émission
et il vaut la sportive américaine megan
willis star du softball a participé la
semaine dernière un atelier à
montigny-le-bretonneux avec des jeunes à
floridienne a donné à cette occasion
quelques conseils et astuces les détails
dans cette édition
cyclisme sur piste le deuxième grand
prix de vélizy-villacoublay programmé ce
dimanche 8 novembre vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines 150
coureurs participeront à la compétition
coup de projecteur à suivre régulier
plaisir à remporter une quatrième
victoire en quatre matches de fédérale 3
les illinois ont battu roanne malmaison
28 à 15 à domicile
retour sur cette rencontre ce magazine
et puis en fin d'émission comme tous les
lundis nous fout rampant complet sur
résultats sportifs du week-end dans le
département nous parlant notamment de la
transat jacques vabre du skipper
versailles et tanguy de lamotte qui est
actuellement à la 5e place du classement
c'était l'évènement à montigny le
bretonneux la sportive américaine megan
willis star du softball le baseball pour
les féminines a participé la semaine
dernière un atelier à
montigny-le-bretonneux
la floridienne a donné à cette occasion
quelques conseils et astuces le montage
est signée romain respini
l'américaine megan willis 30 ans est
l'une des meilleure joueuse de softball
au monde l'équivalent du baseball pour
les féminines au pays de l'oncle sam
ce mardi la joueuse professionnelle a
animé un atelier avec des jeunes au
stade jean maréchal de moutier moto2
pour présenter son sport au programme de
la frappe des cessions pour attraper la
balle et de la défense c'était une
journée très spéciale aujourd'hui
c'était important pour moi d'être là et
de voir autant de jeunes garçons et de
jeunes filles c'était vraiment
fantastique de les voir jouer au
softball et baseball ensemble en france
a dit comment on se plaçait en quatre
heures comment se placer pas en 4/3
en plein d'autres choses cette rencontre
exceptionnelle a été rendue possible
grâce à un partenariat entre la
fédération française de baseball et
l'ambassade des états unis
c'est exceptionnel parce qu'on a une
athlète exceptionnelle et est ce qui est
important c'est de saisir encore une
fois ces opportunités pour montrer à nos
jeunes à nos licenciés en général
d'ailleurs ce qu'est vraiment le
softball et pas simplement une démarche
franco français c'est vraiment ce qu'on
a de mieux aujourd'hui sur le softball
mondiale on l'a ici en continu au total
plus de 60 joueurs de baseball et de
softball se sont inscrits à la session
pour avoir la chance d'être coaché par
la floridienne
bah du coup j'ai posé mon après midi et
est ce que je me suis dit je pense enfin
avoir l'occasion de rencontrer une
joueuse américaine professionnel je
pense on n'aura pas beaucoup l'occasion
dans une vie donc donc j'ai sauté sur
l'occasion et c'est super certaines
filles ont le potentiel pour intégrer
l'équipe nationale
peut-être que les d'entre elles aura
l'opportunité de participer aux
olympiques de 2020 la tournée de megan
willis en france s'achèvera fin octobre
après montigny-le-bretonneux
l'américaine participera des ateliers
softball à lyon et à bordeaux
un événement à ne pas rater pour les
amateurs de cyclisme sur piste le
deuxième grand prix de
vélizy-villacoublay programmé ce
dimanche 8 novembre de 13h30 à 18h30 au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines pour nous parler de ce
rendez-vous nous recevons sur ce plateau
jean michel richefort et michel barraud
bonsoir bonsoir alors jean-michel on va
commencer par vous est ce que ça sera un
très beau rendez vous ce dimanche
oui on a tout fait pour que ce soit un
très beau rendez vous la deuxième
édition du grand prix de vélizy monte en
puissance l'an dernier nous avions 100
vers engagé cette année 150
coureurs ont envoyé leurs engagements et
parmi eux
des champions du monde des champions de
france des coureurs élite
et puis toutes les catégories seront
représentées et comment l expliquez-vous
justement cet engouement il y avait 120
coureurs l'année dernière 157 années
comment l'expliquez vous et bien d'une
part il ya la magie de ce vélodrome le
vélodrome nationale fait rêver et fait
rêver toutes les catégories des dames
des cadets nous aurons plus de 50 cadets
les seniors également mêmes
les champions les champions aiment se
retrouver à saint quentin en yvelines
parce que cette piste elle est magique
michel barrault est ce que est ce qu'au
niveau sera relevé cette année une
quelconque compétition on pourra voir
sur la piste du hub oui le niveau va
être très relevé jean michel en a parlé
niveau national voire même mondial
puisqu'il ya des gens qui sont champions
du monde qui vont participer donc donc
vraiment champion du monde du coup
morgan kneisky qui est champion du monde
avec verve et bryan coquard avec bryan
coquard champion du monde de
l'américaine
on a aussi des membres de l'équipe de
france qui vont participer donc vraiment
un très très beau très beau plateau et
vous le disais c'est au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
le lieu idéal sans eau oui c'est un lieu
idéal c'est une infrastructure
ultramoderne
les experts disent que c'est un des plus
beaux vélodrome au monde et c'est vrai
que courir là c'est quelque chose
d'exceptionnel et
des cadets nous aurons une cinquantaine
de cadets qui vont qui auront la chance
de côtoyer donc des champions du monde
morgan kneisky mais également christelle
ribot qui a été championne du monde
récemment en master 1 manchester est
aussi tout le pôle france les jeunes
espoirs du pôle france qui sont
programmés pour les jeux olympiques de
tokyo
donc en 2020 donc un plateau assez
exceptionnel et puis des coureurs élites
comme émilie auclair qui était champion
de france de demi-fond et des courses de
kering cette année ça c'est le plus
important là pour la première fois dans
le grand prix donc nous avons introduit
les courses kerry qui sont toujours très
spectaculaire avec les meilleurs
coureurs français de guérini et pourquoi
pourquoi avoir justement choisi ce
vélodrome il est magnifique quand on
sait mais est-ce que escaut si ça vous
permet d'avoir du monde d'amis du monde
dans ce pour ce grand prix de vélizy
bien sûr on espère bien donc déjà on a
fait l'entrée est gratuite et on espère
faire découvrir la piste au public
francilien qui a vibré lors des
championnats du monde j'espère que ce
public va nous rejoindre dimanche et
c'est toujours très spectaculaire parce
que l'enceinte s'y prêtent les courses
sont toujours rapide et je pense que
dimanche dans le vélodrome il y aura une
superbe ambiance
michel est ce que les coureurs vous en
parlez seront prêts en devises
oui oui on les côtoie tout au long de
l'année
c'est un événement depuis depuis le
l'exploit de l'année dernière où
effectivement fait désir a réussi une
formidable organisation
tout le monde nous en parle et tout le
monde dit oui nous on veut y aller nous
on veut s'engager
malheureusement c'est un petit peu
limité puisque on ne peut pas accueillir
trop de monde sur la piste mais mais
tous tous ceux qui viennent sont très
très très content de venir et ce sans
entraîner de façon intense bien
évidemment bien évidemment qui viennent
vraiment pour une grosse compétition
assez sinon on va dire en match amical
tout à fait vraiment une vraie
compétition tout à fait c'est une vraie
compétition officielle bien sûr et et
voilà tout le monde va être avoir à
coeur de faire le meilleur résultat
possible
et est-ce qu'il y aura une troisième
édition l'année prochaine mais bien sûr
déjà on a des idées pour faire
progresser encore ce grand prix et
pourquoi pas faire venir des étrangers
et inclure des matchs de vitesse et
préparer ce grand prix sur la journée
avec des épreuves de vitesse le matin
bien sûr les finales l'après-midi mais
toujours nous tenons à conserver toutes
les catégories faire courir les
féminines et meilleure féminine de
france faire courir des cadets également
des juniors ça c'est très important pour
nous et qu'ils puissent côtoyer l'élite
de la piste en france et qu'est ce que
vous aimeriez que les gens retiennent de
cette journée quel serait le plus beau
compliment qu'on pourrait vous faire à
la fin de cette journée et bien on a
pris beaucoup de plaisir et l'ambiance
était formidable
on voudrait recréer l'ambiance qu'on a
connus lors des championnats du monde en
février dernier et c'est possible pour
un club
oui bien sûr c'est possible si le public
est là et c'est la raison pour laquelle
on a fait une entrée gratuite et on
espère qu'il y aura beaucoup de jeunes
beaucoup de familles venir ce dimanche
après midi et on ne doute pas que les
coureurs vont faire le spectacle donc ça
va vibrer encore une fois dans ces deux
rôles merci à tous les deux elle passait
sur ce plateau j'espère qu'elles sont
des vous passionnera les foules comme
vous l'avez dit jean-michel au louvre à
présent une large page rugby le rugby
club de plaisir des finances finit plus
de gagner les événements poursuivre leur
sans-faute dans le championnat de
fédérale 3 ils ont largement dominé à ce
week end à rueil malmaison le score 28
1,15 conséquence le plaisir est premier
du classement
oui ml pour les images quatrième match
et quatrième victoire pour plaisir en
fédérale 3 ce dimanche les rugbymans
heavy nous allons une nouvelle fois pas
fait de détail à domicile face avant et
même maison le score est sans appel 28 à
15 c'est vrai que quatre matches quatre
victoires en sommes pas non plus faire
la fine bouche c'est vrai mais voilà et
on est toujours un petit peu en tant
qu'entraîneur on n'est jamais satisfait
complètement mais il ya quand même la
victoire il faut pas non plus oublier 22
15 il vit paru emporter 10 sièges zéro
point et donc on est quand même je suis
satisfait du résultat
on peut non plus être trop trop
pessimiste avec cette victoire plaisir
caracole en tête du championnat avec 17
points et 119 points marqués depuis le
début de la saison
descendu en fédérale 3 après un passage
éclair à l'échelon supérieur plaisir
veut remonter dès cette année en
on va se donner les moyens j'ai toute la
saison jusqu'au bout quoi parce que bon
on voit et le score d'aujourd'hui où il
y aura aucun match qui sera gagné
jusqu'à la fin de saison il y aura pas
un match facile y aura pas une équipe
qui lâchera on sait qu'en fédérale 3
c'est ces besoins ne s'assied fil sur
tous les impacts et du coup bah voilà le
score reflète la partie quand et la
saison ça sera comme ça jusqu'au bout
donc froid qu'on accroche parce que le
club s'était quand même à bien figurer
en dernier en fédérale 2 il est il avait
perdu juste sur le dernier la dernière
rencontre donc bien sûr que les joueurs
à la nba et l'objectif l'objectif clair
c'est quand même de remonter
immédiatement ferreira le 2 mai jour à
produire autre chose que ce qu'on a fait
aujourd'hui
prochain match pour les yvelinois
dimanche 8 novembre à l'extérieur contre
marcq en baroeul le dauphin de plaisir
au classement après plaisir en reste en
fédérale 3 coup de projecteur à présent
sur la poupe trois équipes de chevreuse
n'y arrive pas les chevrotins se sont
inclinés à domicile contre pontault
combault 21,8 pour nous parler de cette
mauvaise spirale nous recevons sur ce
plateau le coach brice trân trong et
l'entraîneur des trois-quarts stéphane
douchez bonsoir alors tout d'abord je
tenais à vous remercier a tenus sur ce
bateau c'est jamais facile de venir
après une défaite pour les
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent et
qui ne suivent pas forcément avec
attention les résultats de fédérale 3 il
faut remettre un petit peu dans contexte
ces mauvais résultats plaisir descend de
fédérale 2 le reportage quand même juste
avant et par contre vous vous êtes
promis cette année en fédérale 3 c'est
ça s'était vu en début de saison
effectivement on monte monte d'honneur
après une belle saison l'année dernière
et puis il faut composer avec le groupe
qui est resté stable avec le début de
saison ce qui fait que nous en fait en
tant que gay qui montons en fédérale 3
on tombe contre les équipes qui
descendent de fédérale 2 ou qui ont été
dans les premiers de poule l'année
dernière en fédérale 3 donc donc les
matches du début de saison souvent plus
compliqué on espère que le vent va
tourner rapidement et ce qui est à 1
montre la division honneur et la
fédérale 3 donc sentait il ya un nom de
un petit monde un petit monde en tout
cas on travaille pour combler pour
combler les manques que l'importance du
physique là et du potentiel physique et
énergétique est vraiment plus prégnant
quand même en fédérale 3 mais c'est un
peu compliqué ce début de saison
stéphane comment expliquez vous cette
mauvaise passe depuis l'épidémie la
saison pour vous de votre côté c'est
pareil c'est on va dire les premiers
matches qui sont difficiles et si
mauvaise spirale
logique on va dire après tout où est ce
que vous sentez quand même qu'il ya
quelques petits détails qui ont fait la
différence sur ces premiers matchs alors
il ya justement pour en parler des
détails en effet il ya quelques si on
avait peut-être quelques petits trous
dans notre effectif qui fait qu' on
n'arrive pas à passer le cap au moment
où il faut gagner au moment où il faut
marquer il faut scorer
on ne fait pas et dimanche dernier
encore une fois on prend un essai à
dernière action on prend un essai ce qui
alourdit largement score c'était un
petit peu la même chose pour le match
d'avant donc à chaque fois il va nous
manquer le leader
à ce niveau-là et mais par contre non le
nez oignons sens tout à fait qu'on est
au niveau on sent tout à fait qu'on
développe un jeu qui est très agréable
les joueurs prennent beaucoup de plaisir
les supporters aussi les tout ce qu'ils
nous jouent trouve qu'on a et on a
vraiment une équipe qui a un énorme
potentiel et on le développe en a pas un
jeu restrictif
les résultats de la coupe du monde ont
montré que c'était que ça allait payer
d'avoir un jeu sur le fond tourné vers
l'offensive donc on est offensif et on
espère qu'au fur et à mesure ça va payer
les joueurs vont continuer à progresser
à prendre confiance et je veux pas dire
aux autres de faire attention mais on en
est toujours on n'est pas mort et on
arrive et est ce qu'il est un secteur
brice qui vous fait peut-être défaut en
ce début de saison je ne sais pas un
poste clé qui et qui fait basculer la
rencontre
il n'y a rien de lui beaucoup y en a eu
beaucoup on n'a pas été bon on n'a pas
été bon du tout sur les lancements de
jeu les touches notamment le cio et du
score vous n'avez pas été non plus
ridicule non pas du tout comme le disait
stéphane on est on a pris un essai tout
en fin de match donc c'était assez serré
on a fait en fait le plus gros secteur
où on a été n'était pénaliser beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup on a fait beaucoup de
fautes on n'a pas été disciplinés
on a perdu beaucoup de ballons en touche
et on n'a pas mis les points au pied
donc tous les ingrédients pour perdre un
match finalement et est ce que vos
joueurs doit faire peut-être un petit
peu plus sans restera peut-être un petit
peu plus à l'entraînement ou est-ce que
c'est tout simplement logique on avait
l'impression depuis trois semaines on
avait plutôt bien travaillé à
l'entraînement
malgré tout la seule réalité c'est celle
du terrain et force est de constater que
mon a pas été bon hier les joueurs les
joueurs ont leur part de responsabilité
nous aussi certainement à tous de se
remettre en cause et un travail stéphane
quels seront les recettes pour renverser
la vapeur
surtout croire en ce qu'on fait est
vraiment rien lâcher du tout et
s'impliquer s'impliquer et se battre ça
c'est tout d'abord un sport de
commandants se battent et se faire
confiance les uns les autres
est ce que les joueurs eux ils y croient
bien sûr ça bien sûr qu'ils y croient
bien sûr il y croit et on croit même
plus qu'au maintien
donc on a des objectifs qui sont pas
uniquement de maintien on se reconstruit
c'est un club qui en monde qui se
reconstruit et qui a des ambitions et
les objectifs du coup ça sera pas
forcément maintien non mon objectif à
nous on a un à quatre coaches avec
stéphane moins que et les deux coaches
de la baie on est tous dans la même
dynamique c'est à dire que l'on déteste
tous perdre quoi qu'il arrive on déteste
perdre et on nous on vise oui on vise la
qualif
alors maintenant elle phrase frappe à la
limite peu importe mais jusqu'au dernier
au dernier coup de sifflet de la saison
on fera tout pour 1 pour être qualifié
pour pouvoir faire mieux possible et à
ce que finalement ce match leur match
référence de joué-lès-tours la victoire
la seule victoire de la saison est ce
que ça peut permettre de construire un
groupe sur le long terme
vous l'avez emporté lors de la dernière
journée est ce que finalement joué les
tours qui était quand même un bon
morceau quand même de ceux de cette
poule est ce que ça peut permettre de
vous construire de construire un groupe
là dessus
construits moi je pense qu'on construit
aussi sur les défaites
la victoire oui effectivement ça fait du
bien oui à des points positifs à dégager
maintenant faut aussi corriger nos
arrêts ça le plus important c'est de
s'améliorer corriger ce qui n'a pas été
surtout puisque contre joué les tours on
a fait des bonnes choses notamment sur
le secteur de la touche
on a été catastrophique hier donc chaque
dimanche ne se ressemblent pas et essaie
de corriger petit à petit et puis
travail de longue haleine sur une saison
et comment gères justement cette cette
ambiance quand il ya une spirale
négative comment comment gère ça à
d'autres groupes alors déjà nous il n'y
a pas une spirale négative c'est à dire
que les résultats
plus ou moins était plus ou moins
attendue puisque au départ vu que on
savait qu'on allait jouer les équipes
les plus huppées de luppé de la poule
maintenant on ce qu'on leur a dit voilà
nous notre championnat il commence
réellement maintenant et c'est voilà
donc il n'y a pas une spirale négative
on est de plus en plus nombreux à
l'entraînement on les joueurs prennent
du plaisir nous on prend du plaisir
aussi à y venir
il n'y a pas du tout de spirale négative
chine malgré la défaite
l'ambiance est encore bonne ya pas de
souci du tout donc enfermé bri
oui tout à fait c'est sûr c'est sûr et
puis regardez le moral c'est ça oui les
halles
votre discours avant le début du match
oui et puis même si on n'aime pas perdre
toute façon fait toujours tout pour
gagner après garder le moral de toute
façon la côte ils arrivent et je pense
que quand on fait du rugby
chaque match à présent de la même
manière il faut aller à la guerre et
puis et puis il faut faire la guerre et
tant qu'on n'est pas mort on continue et
découvre n'être pas inquiet à cesena ses
traders on est toujours en vie ce que
l'ulcère à chaque mot non mais non on
n'est pas inquiet ou en tout cas autant
stéphane que moins on est positif et on
sait que le travail va payer
peu importe que peu importe quand le
plus rapidement possible mais il va
payer et qu'enfin raté s'inquiétait cela
en grèce
à l'intersaison quand on sera sûr de
descendre lens a manqué en attendant on
va se battre pour les autres qui doivent
s'inquiéter non s'inquiète pas
s'inquiéter
prochain match la victoire du co
prochain match la victoire celui d'après
la victoire et puis et puis quand vous
n'aurez inviterait mi-décembre vous
verrez qu'on sera dans les qualifiés
c'est noté merci à vous d'être passé sur
ce plateau bon courage pour la suite du
championnat on passe maintenant aux
autres résultats du week end
on commence cette page résultat à part
du rugby dans la catégorie des bélascain
les moins de 21 ans va ça il jouait ce
week-end leur premier match de la saison
en championnat
la rencontre s'est pas très bien déroulé
pour les rugbymans évinois versailles
n'a pas fait l'opa contre l'entente
plessis à ces bébés meudon sèvres
score final 40 9 à 5 un résultat logique
les locaux découvre cette année la
catégorie versailles d'ailleurs la seule
équipe du département avoir créé sa
section de moins de 21 ans
on écoute l'entraîneur des mails à ce
qu'un guillaume wagner
sa section était l'idée d'un projet
sportif à la base on a décidé de créer
sa section parce que on a estimé que les
jeunes qui sortaient des juniors de
moins de 18 ans n'était pas prêt
physiquement et techniquement à les
jouer en seniors
donc on s'est dit bah voilà autant que
crée cette catégorie qui n'est pas
obligatoire aujourd'hui mais qui va le
devenir donc autant prendre l'avancé aux
adversaires on est les seuls en dans le
centre 18 janvier seulement donc oui
c'est une particularité
prochain match pour les bélascain
dimanche prochain sur le terrain de
suresnes
on passe au cyclisme où il avait
peut-être aperçu si vous êtes passé du
côté de lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines la semaine dernière
pour la deuxième année consécutive les
riders de l'équipe de france de
cyclo-cross 60 ans se sont entraînés sur
le site dans le cadre de leur
préparation pour les championnats
d'europe une compétition qui sera
organisé le samedi 7 novembre à 8 bergen
aux pays-bas en écoute françois trarieux
le responsable de l'équipe de france
cyclo club cyclo cross sur les
championnats d'europe notaire de 50
alors il est adapté notamment sur la
base de loisirs on a deux trois espaces
qui sont appropriés pour pour avoir des
beaux sites de pratique
après nous la particularité des
championnats d'europe c'est qu'on a un
parcours sablonneux
donc on s'est rendu notamment sur la
commune de fargy pour aller rouler
notamment à la sablonnière qui faisaient
ça permet vraiment de travail manière
spécifique en vue des championnats
d'europe qui auront lieu à isbergues et
nos pays bas et où il ya pas mal de
petits espaces sur des dunes donc c'est
pour ça qu'on a essayé de travailler sur
deux sites pendant le stage une grande
compétition de billard était organisé ce
week-end à fontenay flory plus de 170
joueurs of choisi et placer parmi les
meilleurs en france et à l'étranger se
sont affrontés au gymnase descartes à
l'occasion du 3e open de billard
organisée par la fédération française
le public a notamment pu observer la
star tricolore yannick beaufils deuxième
france en 2014
présentation de cet événement par l'un
des organisateurs laurent hutarovich
était au micro de notre journaliste
william l j'ai poussé la porte de la
mairie il ya quatre ans qui m'ont dit
oui pour la première année j'ai voulu
voir plus maintenant c'est tous les ans
fait à la même époque
et un tournoi qui devrait être
opérationnel le débit arrive bp c'est un
tournoi national voire même
internationale que les étrangers qui
sont avec nous qui l'a 9 dans l'année et
sur les 9,1 par région ce mois ci c'est
à paris n'ont donc à frédéric nous
accueille gentiment puis la quatrième
édition
et à la fin de l'année chez religieuse
individuelle aujourd'hui et demain c'est
une équipe de quatre contre quatre
semaines un point sur la transat jacques
vabre à présent vous le savez le skipper
versailles et tanguy de lamotte
participe actuellement à la compétition
le navigateur est parti avec ses
coéquipières samantha davies le dimanche
25 octobre du port dû avoir à bord de
son imoca initiative coeur victime d'une
avarie vendredi dernier le skipper a
réussi à réparer son bateau il pointe
actuellement la cinquième place du
classement et vise même la quatrième
place on écoute le skipper versailles et
là l'objectif est clairement de se
rapprocher de soufre du couple du nord
qui était juste devant moi qui avais
très proche de journaux il ya quand même
encore cinquantaine de kilomètres mais
bon sur ce qui reste à peu près 4000 km
voire plus de 5000 km et avranches en ce
moment dans l'après-midi depuis ce matin
on arrive à grappiller quelques quelques
longueurs sur lui donc on ne va pas
rapporter l'on regarde pas à la
carrefour d'ordinateurs mais mes noms
qui étaient sympas et maintenant
s'appliquer
le but est fortement définir comme dans
toutes les cours mais de terminer
quatrième les trois pitons devant ils
font un atout charme
on termine à repérer que résultat à part
du football en promotion d'honneur
trappe n'en finit plus de gagner les
joueurs coachés par morgan a aussi ont
terrassé sarcelles sur le score de 6
buts à 2 oui vous m'avez bien entendu un
score qui permet à trappes d'être la
meilleure équipe du championnat
du côté du classement trap est premier
avec 20 points la deuxième équipe
évinoise ou y est à égalité de points et
trappistes joueront dimanche prochain
contre et coin à domicile comme on peut
le voir à l'écran trap est premier du
classement devant auj
qui est la deuxième équipe évinoise de
cette poule on referme ce magazine par
rendez-vous course à pied la troisième
édition de la course royal est
programmée ce dimanche au départ de la
pièce d'eau des suisses à versailles
au programme une course de 10 km une
mode de 20 kilomètres des compétitions
pour les enfants et de la marche
nordique
l'arrivée programmée à fontenay le
fleury si vous voulez vous inscrire
reste encore des places c'est la fin de
cette fuite sport merci d'avoir suivi je
vous retrouve lundi prochain pour un
nouveau magazine d'ici là passez une
excellente semaine sportive très belle
soirée sur tv fil 78